great job let's review what we've done
in this lesson first we made an
interactive prototype using envision
second we've changed it in reaction to
our first round of feedback next we
shared it with subject matter experts
and users and finally we've gotten
feedback using our interactive prototype
in the next lesson we'll talk about how
to bring your prototype to an engineer
to think about getting it built we'll
also talk about how to continue to
iterate your prototype through the rest
of the process finally we'll talk about
using your app prototype to talk about
your app with investors or other people
interested see you in less than 3